et puis on a beaucoup parlé dans les
écoles depuis plusieurs mois les
moisissures se trouvent également
évidemment dans les appartements dans
les logements montréal y en a pleins
côte-des-neiges parc extension ce
problème récurrent mathieu dion
rencontré une femme qui a développé une
hypersensibilité aux champignons un
problème et c'est le cas de le dire qui
empoisonnent il s'agit
d'un stand était tellement intense
pendant 13 ans cette femme de montréal a
vécu avec des colocataires indésirable
dans ses murs des moisissures son
logement a beau avoir été décontaminés
en 2008 sont un handicap au dit qu'elles
conservent des séquelles permanentes la
qualité de vie est complètement
détruite les rêves aussi c'est qu'il n'y
a pas de façon de soigner
l'hypersensibilité chimique multiple
qu'elle a développé les champignons ont
affaibli son système immunitaire
aujourd'hui elle souffre de plusieurs
maladies tous les aliments ma cause
d'un détresse physique la fatigue les
problèmes respiratoires l'incapacité de
travailler voire de fonctionner pour
céder suhner prend des suppléments
beaucoup de suppléments qui lui coûte
cher qu'elle fera avec tous mes repas
sont médecins l'un des spécialistes du
québec confirme le diagnostic
ce sont les premiers de santé qui sont
encore méconnus ou pas bien connu pour
lesquelles il existe un manque
d'expérience tellement méconnu que le
ministère de la santé ne reconnaît pas
l'hyper sensibilité chimique multiple du
à la moisissure des traitements sont à
faire dans d'autres provinces comme
l'ontario mais inexistant au québec tout
sent vraiment seul
et
et autant abandonné par le système ce
sont des dossiers sur des personnes qui
vont effectivement développé une maladie
causée personnes
le médecin de sonia ne suffit plus à la
tâche retirer l'exposition - de sûr
c'est un problème qui complexe parce que
c'est un problème qui devient de plus en
plus répandue dans un grand nom de
boltzmann parce qu'ils vieillissent
manque d'entretien elle ne devrait
inspirer un bien meilleur et au jeu ne
pourrait prédire exactement ce qui va
arriver cette descente sur garde les
gens autour de toi les vers le succès
puis moi je sais que c'est quelqu'un que
nommément de talent même ses passions
doivent être mises de côté quand tout
devient une épreuve
et si mathieu dit à radio-canada en rien
on